et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
aurélien pradié bonjour je vous remercie
beaucoup d'attentes premiers invités
politiques c'est la saison devait être
député du lot secrétaire général des
républicains on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview toujours en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
bonjour fabrice s à redon bonjour oriane
fabrice du groupe ebra les journaux
régionaux de tout l'est de la france
évidemment l'actualité c'est la course
la bataille ça y'est qui est lancé pour
la présidence des républicains bruno
retailleau a officialisé sa candidature
ce week-end eric ciotti l'a fait depuis
plusieurs semaines est-ce que vous
régnez pradier vous êtes candidat à la
présidence du parti je me suis fixé un
calendrier déjà depuis un petit bout de
temps je vais le tenir qui était de
laisser l'été pour mûrir ma décision
dont l'état n'a consulté wii est en
train de s'achever et je vais donc
annoncer dans quelques jours ma décision
c'est pas du tout une coquetterie
simplement je prends ce temps là pour
deux raisons la première c'est que j'ai
besoin dans mon parcours politique de
savoir si c'est quelque chose que j'ai
vraiment envie de faire ou pas on n'est
pas candidat à la présidence des
républicains pour le seul plaisir
d'occuper un poste on est candidat à la
présidence des républicains pour
reconstruire toute une machine pour
rebâtir toute une famille politique et
ça nécessite donc sur soi-même un choix
extrêmement important je le dis parce
qu'ils ont fait ce choix on va lui faire
l'intérieur vous savez si vous allez
être candidat ou pas la volonté de
servir des convictions la volonté d'être
fidèle à cette famille politique à
laquelle j'ai toujours adhéré depuis que
j'ai pris ma première carte politique la
volonté de renouveler la manière dont on
s'adresse aux français je les
profondément tu as crochets au corps et
au coeur et c'est ce que j'ai démontré
depuis quelques années en étant le
candidat est compris dans des élections
très difficile je pense aux élections
régionales en occitanie oui j'ai une âme
de combattant mais ce que je sais aussi
c'est que on ne fait pas une op à sur
les républicains l'idée c'est pas le
concours de celui qui fait pipi le plus
loin c'est pas celui qui montre le plus
ses muscles la question c'est celui qui
aura le plus d'énergie qui a le plus de
de capacité aujourd'hui à rassembler et
à parler aux françaises et aux français
qui doit être déterminant et donc je
prends encore quelques jours pour finir
les consultations que j'ai avec les uns
et les autres que vous savez ça change
on a plutôt l'habitude de voir mon
tempérament mettant un peu va-t-en
guerre comme ne prenant pas toujours le
temps de la réflexion
est-ce que la attendre un peu avant de
vous déclarer attendre encore ce n'est
pas laisser s'installer ce duel ciotti
retailleau est ce que vous croyez
vraiment que ce match-là est celui dont
les adhérents veulent on voit déjà en 72
heures se réinstaller la guerre des
chefs ça y est ça recommence je pense
que plus les jours passent une eau
propre adhérents se disent on va pas
recommencer les matchs d'hier et
d'avant-hier si on veut vraiment
reconstruire dans une période qui est un
champ de ruines pour notre famille
politique
le seul risque ce serait de ne pas
prendre de risques donc vous pourriez
être ce troisième homme qui apporte
autre chose qu'une guerre des chefs dès
lors que j'aurai pris ma décision oui ça
pourrait être cette alternative là et qu
est-ce qu elle apparaît depuis pas de
candidature par rapport aux deux
candidatures des gens c'est aussi le
travail que j'ai engagées durant cet été
être candidat à la présidence des
républicains c'est aussi avoir un
message adressé non seulement aux
adhérents mais aussi aux français si on
n'est pas candidat pour présider un
grand parti comme l'a été les
républicains qui le parti héritier du
général de gaulle pour seulement parler
un clan on est candidat à la présidence
des républicains si on sait ce que l'on
veut dire aux françaises et aux français
moi je n'adhère pas à cette idée que à
droite on aurait désormais une culture
de l'échec à sculptures de l'échec à
droite a une culture de la réussite vous
n'avez au match on a réussi le doute à
aucun moment vous êtes dit on va
disparaître les républicains vont
disparaître la droite dite républicaine
peut disparaître à 6 e doute là il
faudrait être aveugle ou dans le déni le
plus absolu pour ne pas la voir tête et
je le redis si je mesure la gravité de
cette décision que je ne veux pas
multiplier une candidature pour le
plaisir de multiples candidatures si je
refuse la guerre des chefs qui est en
train de s'installer et que donc se
repose à nouveau pour moi la question de
comment peut-être jeu j'incarne une
alternative à cette guerre des chefs
mais encore là trop de nature éviterait
la guerre des chefs est-ce que ça serait
pas une candidature de plus c'est toutes
les questions que je me pose je pense
simplement que des trois candidats
potentiels si je prenais la décision
d'être candidat je suis celui qui
ne sait pas abîmer dans des matchs
passés y compris à l'intérieur de notre
propre famille politique et je
dirais je sais les immenses qualités que
c'est le sont celles de bruno retailleau
qui a participé de très près à la
campagne de françois fillon je sais les
immenses qualités qui sont celles des
riches aussi je le dis pas pour leur
faire plaisir je dis parce que je le
pense mais je pense simplement qu'à ce
moment là de notre vie politique ont
tous les autres partis politiques sont
en train de changer tous sont en train
de faire respirer et leurs idées et leur
manière de faire si les républicains
sont les seuls à ne pas changer nous n'y
arriverons pas heynckes une guerre des
chefs elle est en train de
vous il veut changer le parti sur le
fond il a d'ailleurs décrit il n'ya
plusieurs mois maintenant un livre des
centaines de pages avec des idées pour
refonder le parti s'appelait refondation
d'ailleurs ce nul ce qu'on comprend pas
ces caisses qui différencierait votre
éventuelle candidature de la sienne pas
si je suis candidat vous le sur les
d'abord et une paire de demis rassure
pardon pour compléter pts et où la
question génération et paraît pas
fondamental si sûrement une enquête
longue vous n'en faites pas un homme qui
n'en fait pas un enjeu d'abord ça se
voit sur ma tête l'un d'eux le répéter
dix mille fois et puis la question de
génération ne fait pas la qualité
nécessairement ce que je sais simplement
c'est que ça fait du bien aussi et ça
fera sûrement du bien à nos adhérents
peut-être d'être représentés
différemment c'est certain
est-ce que pour vous clairement eric
ciotti bruno retailleau sont trop à
droite aujourd'hui non ils sont pas trop
à droite on appartient à la même famille
politique on a donc des fondamentaux qui
sont exactement les mêmes ce débat de
l'insee réplique sur l'aide sociale non
je suis sur une conviction populaire
rien à voir et pas la droite sociale
c'est la droite populaire voici à quoi
je crois c'est la droite qui parle à
tout le monde à droite qui fait du
combat pour nous ouvrir y est pour nos
caissières pour nos infirmiers un combat
aussi essentiel que celui pour
l'économie du très haut niveau c'est ce
à quoi je crois je crois vous rendez
compte que la droite française ne parle
plus aux jeunes nous avons moins de 4%
des jeunes français qui ont voté pour
les candidats de la droite républicaine
lors de l'élection de présidentielle
mais aussi avant moi dans le lot comme
beaucoup de mes collègues on a relevé ce
défi je suis député d'une terre de
gauche et j'ai toujours assumé mes
convictions jeu mais j'ai jamais renier
et celles et ceux qui ont voté pour moi
ressemble à la france d'une droite
populaire ce cette nécessité d' incarner
une droite populaire elle est
fondamentale et de faire respirer cette
famille politique enfin j'ajoute une
chose eric ciotti a aujourd'hui de
grandes responsabilités et les questeurs
à l'assemblée nationale les présidents
notre commission nationale d'investiture
il sera demain je lui souhaite parce
qu'il en a les qualités une très grand
maire de nice bruno retailleau et
président du groupe au sénat et nous
avons un besoin essentiel d'avoir au
sénat un groupe parlementaire qui tient
la barre est ce que à un moment on doit
toujours prendre les mêmes pour occuper
les mêmes postes et ce quoi pour vous
c'est pas possible de cumuler de telles
responsabilités soient questeur soir
président de groupe avec la présidence
du parti et je sais que bruno a
largement les capacités de travail pour
le faire c'est pas le problème problème
c'est que vient un moment où cette
famille politique de la droite
républicaine doit aussi savoir faire
confiance aux uns et aux autres on
sous-estimé une chose pour ce qui est de
la présidence des républicains c'est pas
un poste honorifique ce poste
intellectuelle être président des
républicains aujourd'hui c'est aussi
reconstruire la machine c'est aussi être
mécanicien accepté de mettre les mains
dans le cambouis de faire le tour des
fédérations les unes après les autres
comment alors comment la reconduire
c'est tout le travail qui est apportée à
la fois de l'intérieur lui parce qu'on
sous estime parfois le rôle intérieure
du président des républicains qui est de
remonter cette cette machinerie et pour
le reste je le redis la droite sera
populaire où elle ne sera plus populaire
populiste
la frontière est parfois ténue
hervé morin vos amis centristes famille
centriste hervé maurey les centristes
sont inquiets quand une possible
radicalisation de la ligne des
républicains contre vous
positionnez-vous ce sujet notre seule
porte de sortie celle qui d'ailleurs
peut nous enthousiasmer c'est celle de
redevenir populaire redevenir populaire
ça veut dire placer la valeur du travail
au coeur de la vie de chacun je souhaite
demain pouvoir m'adresser à laquelle la
caissière du coin de la rue en lui
disant voilà ce que la droite va faire
pour vous oui vous travaillez dur oui
vous produisez des efforts oui vous est
essentielle à notre pays alors nous nous
allons vous accompagner y compris sur la
question des salaires depuis quand la
droite républicaine n'at-elle pas eu d'
imagination et je vois que ça progresse
mais des idées que je portais il ya
quelques temps faisait passer pour fou
aujourd'hui elle ne s'installe dans le
paysage politique sur l'écologie on ne
peut pas laisser l'écologie c'est trop
important à tous ces écolos dingo qui
nous explique qu'il faut plus faire de
barbecue et se baigner dans la piscine
on peut pas laisser tous ces sujets
fondamentaux à d'autres et sur ces
questions là la droite républicaine elle
doit revenir au coeur des préoccupations
des français viennent des connexions
trop grand entre ce que les uns et les
autres et j'en fais partie nous avons pu
lire depuis des années les
préoccupations des français et c'est ce
chemin là qu'il nous faut trouver je ne
sais pas si les populistes ou en quad
autre peu importe il s'intéresse à la
vie quotidienne des français je crois
qu'on a eu une forme de snobisme
intellectuel pas qu'à droite dans la vie
politique globalement depuis quelques
années dans notre démocratie consistant
à dire que seuls certains sujet méritait
d'être traité par le politique sujet qui
était très haut et que les blessures du
quotidien des français ça n'était pas à
la hauteur du politique je crois à l'
inverse d'ailleurs lorsque jacques
chirac gagne des élections
présidentielles en 1995 il le fait avec
des vraies valeurs et en parlant au
quotidien des français lorsque nicolas
sarkozy en 2007 avant que ne se gâtent
gagner l'élection présidentielle
il le fait en parlant de la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires en sujets très concrets
qui vient incarner une valeur travail
moi je souhaite que la droite française
elle ne redevienne imaginative et puis
enfin est-ce que ça va vous avez trop
parler de sujets régaliens trop parler
de sécurité trop parler d'immigration et
que c'était pas ça le bonheur nous
n'avons pas assez parlé du reste
évidemment qu'il faut dire à nos
concitoyens ce que nous allons faire en
matière d'immigration c'est un sujet
absolument essentiel et je ferai
moi-même des propositions dans les mois
qui viennent que je sois candidat ou que
je ne le sois pas pour montrer qu'elle
est ma vision sur ces sujets extrêmement
ferme mais que dit on sur tout le reste
tout ce qui fait la vie des françaises
et des français notre vie votre vie est
comme l'écologie par exemple oui comme
l'écologie oui j'ai dit depuis plusieurs
plusieurs semaines que nous devions nous
réapparaître ce sujet sur deux ans le
premier c'est la question de l'eau oui
la question de l'eau qui paraît être
secondaire et qui est fondamental nous
avons un immense défi aujourd'hui dans
notre pays comme dans le monde sur la
question de l'accès à l'eau et nous
avons là une ressource d'innovation
absolument colossal de des retenues
d'eau jusqu'à la gestion de l'eau
potable
c'est notre vision de l'environnement là
où les écologistes intégristes vont vous
dire si demain vous voulez gérer la
ressource en eau il faut vous priver
d'eau dont nous allons dire avec
l'innovation nous allons mieux contrôler
mieux organiser notre consommation d'eau
ça c'est un vrai défi piano défi qui est
celui de la société de surconsommation
que je ne veux pas laisser aux
extrémistes oui moi je ne me résous pas
à ce que notre monde demain soit celui
qui consomme tentées tant de textile que
nous ne porterons même pas je ne me
résous pas à ce que notre acte de
consommation quotidiens se fasse vers
des produits qui ont traversé le monde
c'est absurde et je crois donc à la
souveraineté alimentaire industriel et
je pense que sur cette société de la
surconsommation nous avons quelque chose
à dire je relisais hier dans le train
georges pompidou et georges pompidou
lui-même disait à quel point ce qu'il
nous fallait c'était il ya quelques
décennies déjà ce serait sortir de la
société de l'abondance pour que l'homme
retrouve toute sa valeur et bien moi je
pense qu'on peut sortir de la société de
l'abondance non pas par la punition mais
par l'organisation de nos modes de
consommation
tous ces valeurs un point commun avec
emmanuel macron rica
dans les paroles peut-être la différence
est qu emmanuel macron et tom baratineur
et que je tâche de ne pas l'être je
tâche avoir des solutions concrètes un
dernier mot sur les républicains après
évidemment on va parler du budget du
pouvoir d'achat est ce que pour vous il
faut désigner très vite votre candidat à
la présidentielle et est ce que ce
candidat à la présidentielle doit être
le président du parti à l'évidence celui
qui présidera le parti ne sera pas le
président le candidat à l'élection
présidentielle c'est ce qui commence à
se décider je joue quand même vous dire
que dit eric ciotti qui dit ça ça
devrait être laurent wauquiez pour vous
aussi ça veut dire que si vous êtes
candidat à la présidence du parti elle
ne serait pas candidat à la pression je
dirai le moment venu il faut quand même
que décorrélée les deux oui il faut
découvrir les deux mais attention
attention à ce que présidait le parti et
que les républicains ne devienne pas
simplement une machine de télégraphiste
on n'est pas là pour chauffer la place
d'ailleurs de quoi ont besoin nos futurs
candidats à l'élection présidentielle y
compris laurent wauquiez qui s'y prépare
et qui en a toutes les qualités et qui
seraient mous dans sa préparation
aujourd'hui il est celui qui démontrent
une vraie gravité il est il est souvent
présenté comme le seul à pouvoir y aller
avoue aujourd'hui quelques mois et ça
vous paraît aujourd'hui il est celui qui
dit toute sa préparation et on ne va pas
vers les françaises et les français je
parle de georges pompidou tout à l'heure
sans être profondément préparé il est
dans cette phase de préparation et je
pense que c'est extrêmement respectueux
à l'égard des françaises et des français
mais je veux simplement vous dire que
l'enjeu de la présidence républicaine ne
se résume pas à chauffer la place pour
l'un ou pour l'autre sinon le parti
disparaîtra puisque d'ailleurs tous les
candidats putatifs à l'élection
présidentielle ont eux mêmes dit que ça
ne passerait plus par l'est républicain
par le parti et donc il faut que le
président des républicains domaine soit
pas un exécutant il faut qu'il soit
aussi quelques qui tracent l'avenir
potentiellement pour nos candidats à
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 27
mais je ne voudrais pas et je pense que
nos adhérents en ont conscience nos
adhérents ne veulent pas que l'on résume
la lections à la présidence républicaine
comme l'élection de l'intérim de plus
non il faut que le voter pour le
président des républicains demain ce
soit un investissement pour l'avenir on
va parler du budget puisque gabriel
attal a fait une composition rien une
nouvelle méthode d'examen de ce budget
il veut les parlementaires discutent
avec lui du budget en amont de sa
présentation au conseil des ministres
est ce que vous vous êtes pressée
discussion en discussion évidemment bon
l'a toujours fait c'est bien parce que
les royals à talent comme nous le maire
comme tant d'autres ont été frappés
d'une grâce incroyable qui est celle de
la volonté de discuter ce sont les mêmes
il ya cinq ans ils ont pas changé il en
a même têtes les mêmes cravate il
pensait même chose qui nous ont claqué
la porte dans le nez à chaque fois que
nous avions une proposition intéressante
mais je dis à gabriella talent comme à
ses camarades du gouvernement qu'il ne
faut pas nous prendre pour des
andouilles et que discuter c'est une
chose se rallier c'en est une autre
jamais pour ma part je ne me rallierai à
emmanuel macron l'acte de vote du budget
c'est un acte politique plus raconter ce
que vous voulez à nos concitoyens quand
vous voter le budget c'est un moment
politique beaucoup plus que techniques
qui vous positionne sur l'échiquier
politique je ne fais pas partie de la
majorité des manuels macron donc quel
que soit ce budget quel que soit ce code
contient 5 voidrays contre je ne voterai
pas le budget et vous ne voterez vous
abstenir je voterai contre on voit très
parce que c'est un acte politique et je
le redis ça n'empêchera pas que nous
battrons pour obtenir comme nous l'avons
fait sur la d conjugale isation de
l'allocation adulte handicapé sur les
rtt et tant d'autres sujets pour obtenir
des choses auxquelles nous croyons mais
le vote du budget c'est un vote
politique c'est quand même très curieux
que désormais dans notre fonctionnement
institutionnel on en soit arrivé à
oublier des repères oui c'est un acte
politique et donc l'acte politique je ne
passerai pas vous poussez pas le
gouvernement utiliser le 49-3 temps
c'est son problème gouvernement n'a pas
la majorité les français pardon n'ont
pas donné à emmanuel macron la majorité
il prendra ses responsabilités mais les
républicains ne sont pas là pour filer
un coup de main aux gouvernants chacun
son affaire qu'ils assument comme des
grands garçons que vous disent vos
électeurs votre circonscription dans
cette situation où le gouvernement n'a
plus une majorité absolue il nous me
disent deux choses je suis dans une
circonscription de gauche j'ai toujours
été très clairement affirmée comme
quelqu'un de droite et mes électeurs me
disent deux choses qu'ils soient de
droite ou de gauche battez vous pour
nous c'est ce que nous avons fait pour
la série d'éruptions pour la france et
pour la circonscription et pour la
france pour les deux mais lorsque je me
bats pour des conjugue alizés
l'allocation adulte handicapé qui n'est
pas un petit sujet sujet éminemment
politique qui dit quelque chose à nos
concitoyens des blessures que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure je me bats pour les
lotoises et les lotois et je me bats
pour les français et pour une certaine
idée de mon propre pays est ce qu'ils me
disent aussi c'est soyez clair soyez
clair vous confondez pas avec les uns
les autres assumez vos convictions pas
par sectarisme mais dites vous habitez
on a besoin aussi d'un an démocratie de
repères et donc n'allait pas bidouiller
avec les uns et avec les autres
n'allaient pas perdre votre âme on a un
sujet que nous avons perdu en politique
un mot que nous avons oublié en
politique ne perdons pas notre âme en
politique c'est d'ailleurs en retrouvant
un peu d'âme politique pour les uns et
pour les autres un peu de sincérité un
peu d'authenticité que je pense et
français feront à nouveau un peu
confiance en leurs politiques il ya une
question qui fait débat c'est la
question des superprofits de la taxation
des supers profits est ce que vous vous
êtes favorables à cette taxation je
pense que c'est un débat que nous devons
avoir sans être taxé d'affreux
communiste ou d'affreux libéral
lorsqu'on la religion ce que ce que le
général de gaulle disait ce que ce que
jacques rue f10 économistes majeur du
général de gaulle considéré que dans la
fiscalité il y avait deux dimensions la
dimension symbolique et la dimension de
techniques et on ne doit pas oublier ni
l'une ni l'autre ce que je crains avec
la taxation des supers profits ces deux
choses d'abord c'est que
on en vienne à augmenter l'ensemble des
taxes on commence par le petit bout et
puis on finit par manger y compris le
petit artisan ça je le refuse
catégoriquement il faut mettre frein
définitif à la manie de taxation
permanente deuxième crainte que j'ai
c'est que beaucoup des super profits
sont offerts l'étranger et donc nous
allons axer sur notre sol ce qui ne sera
pas taxée allure et donc perdre encore 1
attractivité est ce que je dis aussi
c'est qu'on ne peut pas laisser
s'installer dans le pays le sentiment
que les entreprises forêt de l'argent
sur le dos de nos concitoyens et je
pense même que les chefs d'entreprises
de même pour en avoir discuté avec les
plus libéraux les plus capitalistes
savent que le grand danger qui les
guette c'est cette contamination
c'est cette idée qu'au fond ils seraient
tous en train de faire des supers
profits et moi je ne veux pas demain que
l'artisan boulanger qui va devoir
augmenter le prix de sa production parce
que ces matières premières ont augmenté
soit taxée de spéculer et c'est pour ça
qu'il me semble qu'il faut mettre de
l'ordre chez ceux qui pourraient
profiter de la situation la meilleure
réalisation pour les familles la
meilleure manière de le faire c'est que
les grands groupes qui sont concernés le
disent eux mêmes et que eux mêmes
apporte une contribution volontaire
s'ils ne le font pas il faut avoir une
autre discussion mais je leur dis
parfois on dit mais vous n'êtes pas très
libérale si en réalité je lis beaucoup
et en voulant faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas une mauvaise ambiance qui
contamine l'ensemble des entreprises
notre pays je suis sûrement en réalité
en disant cela un de ceux qui visent à
le mieux préserver notre modèle
économique libéral est capitaine on
s'arrêtera clairement favorable à la
taxation des supers profits pour les
grands groupes je suis d'accord pour que
nous ouvrions ce débat là avec les
critères que j'ai posées sans dogme sens
sans course à l'échalote sereinement
mais une fois de plus pour faire en
sorte que notre modèle économique puisse
être préservé on a vu on a eu un cahier
quelques jours avec total qui a pris
d'initiative si vous semblez l'autre
leur dire aux grands groupes prenaient
la malaisie montrez nous ce que vous
pouvez faire
total fait un cadeau et ristournes à ses
clients c'était une bonne idée par
rapport à l'économie française et au
reste de la profession total ne fait pas
de cadeaux tout elle rend un peu de ce
qu'ils ont gagné un peu facilement
depuis depuis quelques années vous savez
beaucoup de nos concitoyens comprendra
facilement ce que je suis en train de
dire nous avons une vraie question sur
les autoroutes je suis navré mais je
vais peut-être me faire un peu au spi y
ait par les uns et les autres mais on a
quand même une vraie question sur
quelques bons profits qui sont faits par
les entreprises de gestion autoroutière
aujourd'hui et tout ça vous voyez ça
crée un sentiment de défiance si on veut
demain retrouver la confiance entre nos
concitoyens le consommateur et nos
entreprises il faut que tout le monde
soit le plus exemplaire possible si on
peut éviter d'en passer par la loi c'est
encore mieux et je pense que cette
réflexion est en train de faire son
chemin ce qui inquiète les français
c'est évidemment la hausse des prix de
l'énergie gabriela talent a annoncé ce
week-end que le bouclier énergétique
serait maintenue en 2023 il a eu raison
oui le bouclier énergétique et la
solution d'urgence mais attention ça
fait trop longtemps que nous sommes dans
l'urgence désormais se posait une
question fondamentale notre souveraineté
énergétique oui au nucléaire oui nous
devons relancer le nucléaire en urgence
absolue nous allons faire en sorte qu'on
posait manière oui mais après avoir
saboté
massacré notre parc nucléaire ce qui est
absolument irresponsable le chef de
l'état le gouvernement ont une faute
politique majeure en ayant démantelé
notre parc nucléaire si nous voulons
demain maîtrisé à nouveau les coûts de
l'énergie et principalement de
l'électricité il nous faut retrouver une
souveraineté nucléaire je propose donc
que nous relancions le parc nucléaire
que nous relancions la filière c'est à
dire former des jeunes à ces métiers du
nucléaire que nous avons perdus depuis
tant d'années et puis j'ajoute une
dernière proposition
nous devons nous poser la question de
sortir les coûts de l'énergie des
marchés boursiers tels qu ils ne sont
aujourd'hui je pense que sur la scène
européenne nous avons une vraie question
pas de sortir du marché européen
j parce que ça me paraît compliqué à ce
stade mais en tous les cas fait en sorte
que le coût de l'énergie soit mieux
maîtrisée par les états eux mêmes et que
nous ne soyons pas soumis à une
spéculation boursière et européennes sur
sur ces sujets est une vraie réflexion
peut être même que la question de la
sortie du marché européen de
l'électricité ou de l'énergie est une
question nous devons nous poser une
dernière question enfin vous avez se
pose sur l'énergie elle peut se poser
sur des tas d'autres notamment des
transports etc oui c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que j'ai une réserve mais à
ceci près que sur l'énergie nous pouvons
être souverain que la question nucléaire
notamment nous permettrait de retrouver
une souveraineté et c'est pour ça que je
pense que cette question elle n'est pas
sa passion merci aurélien pradié
beaucoup savard est un des premiers
invités politiques de la saison merci
s'adresse à redon
[Musique]